senator cortez masto
thank you i too let me echo my
colleagues to
uh thank you senator murkowski you've
done an incredible job
uh working with everybody on the
committee to make sure our all of our
voices were heard and working with our
legislation so thank you for that great
work
governor granholm congratulations
welcome to your
husband and thank you for taking the
time to talk with me i'm going to get
right to it
and utilize some of the questions that i
have that are very specific to nevada my
colleague from maine highlighted one of
them
yucca mountain we know it has been a
failed policy
uh nuclear waste act it's been there for
the since 1980
we still have challenges with really
addressing
the high level nuclear waste storage
that we have in this country
yucca mountain is not the answer and the
couple of questions that i have for you
is first what is this administration's
position on yucca mountain
yeah the administration opposes the use
of yucca mountain for
storage of nuclear waste thank you and
will you commit the department to
working with congress to develop
safe and workable alternatives to echo
mountain absolutely
okay and will you be sure to have the
staff responsible for nuclear waste
planning and management engage with
my office yes thank you as well as the
office of senator rosen
yes and then you you mentioned it the
the blue ribbon panel we know that the
blue ribbon panel made
recommendations around consent-based
siting process
uh senator rosen and i along with the
entire nevada delegation will
reintroduce this legislation
to include nevada in that consent based
sighting
um and is that something that you and
the administration would support
absolutely thank you and the final
question around
yucca is just to make sure that uh if
you're nominated you and the
administration would commit to engaging
the state's
tribes and key stakeholders on
developing that consent based sighting
yes thank you uh let me jump to one
other issue which is uh the storage
of uh plutonium nevada has a
national uh security site we are very
proud of it
creates jobs we are an important part of
the national security as you well know
in this country uh in 2018 the state of
nevada learned that the trump
administration had secretly
shipped plutonium intended for weapons
production
to nevada to be stored indefinitely at
the nevada national site
i agreed and working with the department
of energy
we came to an agreement which the state
used to secure a settlement with the
department
last year to begin removing the
plutonium
from nevada what is the current status
of does and the national nuclear
security administration's plan for
removing
the plutonium if you know yeah the plan
is to follow the agreement that you
negotiated
thank you i appreciate that um and let
me just
add this in 2014 the obama
administration and state of nevada
agreed to establish
a senior level doe nevada working group
to address mutual concerns about
operations
at the nevada national security site
unfortunately the trump administration
did not follow through on that agreement
will you commit to re-establish the doe
nevada working group with regular
meetings of senior level personnel
yes i will thank you
and then let me address the in general
the conversation because i so agree
uh listen i i support uh a
really a diverse energy portfolio for
all states every state is going to be
unique in nevada
we have natural gas we have geothermal
we have wind we have solar
but the outcome for all of us should be
reducing that carbon footprint and i do
believe
in an innovation economy is coming if
it's not already here and the technology
is going to give us that opportunity
to to really engage in a clean energy
portfolio for so many of us it's going
to create jobs it's going to move us in
that direction and there's opportunities
to bring everybody along with us let me
talk a little bit about
electric vehicles because this is
something that i so agree with you i
have a suite of electric vehicle
legislations one of them is including
the infrastructure package
if you come to nevada and i i've offered
to you before
you will see in some of our rural
communities we already have the
infrastructure for electric vehicles
i'm very proud of that but let me let me
ask you one of the pieces of legislation
that i have that i'm going to be
introducing is to establish a working
group
that's co-led by doe to improve that
coordination
among local state and federal
stakeholders to establish
a clear strategy and national electric
vehicle framework but that includes not
just
cars but buses as well is that something
that you could work with us on or would
be willing to engage
absolutely thank you i appreciate that
i noticed my time is up the rest of the
questions i have here i'll submit for
the record thank you again and
congratulations
thank you thank